what makes our dramaturgy program as
successful as it is is that we are
attached to this already fast-moving
kinetic powerful conservatory program
dramaturgy is the set of techniques and
choices that an artist makes in the
process of bringing an inert script into
a live piece of performance the
dramaturgical question is why this plan
out which i think is so so pertinent and
and crucial to any art form which is how
do we talk to an audience what is the
best way to communicate what combines
history at a combines creativity and in
kind of all the gamut that I wanted to
pursue in first coming to Carnegie
Mellon the dramaturg is someone who is
good at uncovering information and
transforming it into knowledge which is
practical information information that
can be then used and integrated into a
performance to create an artistic whole
so you can have a traditional route just
working for a theater or you can go into
script doctoring and working directly
with texts if you're interested in
creating and critically analyzing the
arts and understanding how it impacts a
society then you should consider
dramaturgy